well uh what does labor think the shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
is here with us good morning thanks for
joining us so ambulance workers on
strike uh Grant Shep says they're
putting lives at risk what do you think
I think the last thing that paramedics
and ambulance staff want to do is go out
and strike and it's the last thing they
want to be doing today of course we saw
during the last round of strikes that
where it comes to emergency calls they
will of course go out and respond
they'll leave the picket lines
um they've come into the NHS because
they believe in helping patients and in
public service and I think it's down to
this government's failure to properly
negotiate and to give them a good decent
Fair pay settlement that we've ended up
in this terrible mess labor also being
accused of putting lives at risk by
moving to block new strike laws
what the government is talking about is
just a total distraction from the
failure not just in recent times but
over the last 13 years to actually get a
proper deal for all of our brilliant
public sector workers I don't think what
the government has set out is workable I
don't think it's right and I would
recommend to ministers that they spend a
bit more time trying to resolve these
disputes get around the table speak to
the unions sort it out don't waste your
time with this kind of unworkable
legislation it works in Spain we're told
it works in other parts of Europe as
well including France well in France
they've seen increases in the strikes
that are happening and in Spain it's
subject to significant legal challenge
so I just don't think it's the answer I
don't think it's right the way to
resolve this the way to resolve any
dispute is to talk and to try and find a
compromise and find a way through this
but ministers are more interested in
just getting people in having a photo
pretending they're doing something
rather than actually having a serious
and meaningful discussion to try and
resolve those disputes the same story in
education we've had five education
secretaries in the last year
um we've known for very very long time
that the potential for industrial action
was coming ministers have done nothing
they've not talked about it and now at
the last minute they say let's have a
conversation but we're not really
willing to talk about pay what kind of
negotiation is that uh well I'm glad you
Brock came onto education your area of
course what minimum level of service
should teachers abide by well as I
understand that the education secretary
isn't proposing that in the first round
of this legislation schools or education
will be covered but I think in those
areas where the government are talking
about at minimum levels I think patients
at the minute on non-strike days would
quite like to know that there are
minimal minimal level minimum levels of
service available to you because you
can't get an ambulance at the moment
when you ring on a non-strike day so
should there be a minimum level of
service with teachers the reason I ask
you that is because I had a
representative of the National Education
Union on yesterday and he couldn't rule
out the strikes during the exam period
Well I don't want strikes to happen in
our schools neither the teachers I mean
all they want to see is Improvement in
working conditions and a better deal
where it comes to pay that's why today
in the House of Commons we're pushing
for a vault around the tax status of
private schools because if we ended
those tax benefits that private schools
enjoy we could raise 1.7 billion pounds
that we could put into making sure we've
got more teachers in our classrooms
we're driving up standards because that
will make a massive difference to
teachers workload if they weren't having
to constantly cover for all of these
gaps that the conservatives have loved
to open up yeah but my question is and
I'll come back to the the legislation
but my question is should there be a
minimum level of service from teachers
so that they do have to work during this
as during exam season I I don't think
the legislation is the answer at all in
any area but as I say this is not being
proposed at the minute by the government
where it comes to education but in those
areas where it is being proposed I'd
quite like ministers to deliver minimum
standards a minimum standard that when
you ring an ambulance you guarantee to
get one within a good period on a
non-strike day a minimum standard where
it comes to access to general practice a
minimum standard where it comes to any
so you don't wait for hours on end in a
trolley if you get seen at all that's
the failure of ministers so rather than
seeking distractions around pointless
legislation they should focus on their
own jobs let's go back to your
legislation that you want to binding
vote in the House of Commons on ending
tax breaks enjoyed by private schools
which is soon prime minister has said he
accused actually kirst armor of
attacking the hard-working aspiration of
millions of people in this country
the attack actually is Rishi sunak's
attack on the aspiration of the vast
majority of parents and these children
in this in this country who send their
children to State schools the vast
majority of parents do that and suggests
that somehow that they don't have high
aspirations for their children I think
it's deeply insulting
in terms of the money that would be
raised from this policy at 1.7 billion
pounds a year go straight into schools
it would go directly into our schools in
delivering six and a half thousand new
teachers better mental health support in
our schools and careers guidance and
work experience for young people and
also support for new heads coming
through because what I hear a lot from
current head teachers is that they're
worried about where the Next Generation
they've had teachers is coming from and
we would make sure that we're driving up
standards but you've got to have
brilliant teachers and Brilliant head
teachers in our schools to make that
happen
um talk to me about Westminster accounts
I know that you've been monitoring it
along with many of your colleagues a
company called mpm connect we've been
talking about them a lot they were found
by Westminster accounts to be the third
biggest donor to MP since the last
general election they've given a total
of 345 000 pounds to Yvette Cooper Dan
Jarvis and also West streeting all labor
MPS momentum have described that as dark
money what do you say I don't know the
details of the company all I can say is
speaking for myself all of the donations
that I've received have been checked and
are consistent with the rules and checks
have been made on the donors and I
haven't personally received any money
directly to me okay but I'm sure that
you did see
um the report from our own Sam coats has
been working incredibly hard on this and
he went to the offices of mpm connect
we're not saying they're doing anything
illegal but there was nobody there to
talk to us so there was nobody there who
could tell us about the donations that
were being made to these high-profile
labor MPS should there be further
investigation further transparency into
these sort of donations I do believe we
need further transparency overall where
it comes both to finance of political
parties but also some of those changes I
think we need to see in Westminster too
and I know you've today been talking
about all party groups I think there is
the need further change in a tightening
up of the rules there but I do welcome
but that'd be funded by Parliament
there's all Parliament pollen all party
parliamentary groups I'm going to say
appg it's easier to say should they be
funded by Parliament or is it okay that
lobbying firms give them money I think
what's missing is the transparency that
we need to see around that so I think
there should be greater transparency and
Tighter rules around it I know that this
is being actively considered and I do
think we need to see progress on it but
where it comes to donations to labor I
do welcome the fact that many donors
order new
um want to donate in order to secure a
labor government I think that's welcome
there's nothing in return for that other
than they want us to focus on delivering
that next Labor government and do you
dream of the day that weighed a 2.8
million pounds for speaking engagements
uh no that's not I that's not my thing
if I'm honest no okay good answer thank
you very much as always thanks very much
Andy for joining us thank you